vous le savez ce sujet s'est propulsé
dans la campagne électorale
l'histoire du niqab laisser madame rail
chaque quand vous voyez qui est un peu
malgré elle mais qui est à l'origine de
tout ça elle avait demandé de pouvoir
assister à la cérémonie avec son niqab
la cour lui a donné raison au bon bref
vous connaissez l'histoire
je rejoins catherine brulotte à toronto
c'est que madame henri chaque et
maintenant citoyenne canadienne la
fameuse cérémonie dont on parle depuis
des semaines elle a eu lieu aujourd'hui
voilà après un combat de près de deux
ans
madame général chaque a finalement
obtenu sa citoyenneté officiellement
aujourd'hui
d'abord elle avait refusé de participer
à une cérémonie parce qu'ils me
directives ministérielles empêchait de
conserver son niqab donc son voile
musulman et elle a donc contesté cette
directive devant les tribunaux vous
l'avais dit à la fois la cour fédérale
et la cour fédérale d'appel lui ont
donné raison
disons que cette directive n'était pas
ne correspondait pas la loi canadienne
si bien que c'est cet après midi qu'elle
a finalement prêter ce serment elle a
fait devant un très petit groupe de
personnes parce qu'elles voulaient
justement éviter toute cette tempête
mais elle a quand même permis une équipe
de radio canada et de celui-ci d'être
présent vous invite à entendre sa
réaction à la sortie justement de cette
cérémonie est avant tout son long dans
ces choses je sais pas si on lui a
demandé me suis posé la question est-ce
que si on l'avait forcée la s'est battu
pour le garder mais si la loi avait été
changée au canada et qu'on lui demandait
de d'assister à cette cérémonie le
visage dévoilé leur et elle fait ou non
en fait on lui a offert à deux reprises
lors de cérémonies précédentes elle a
toujours était toujours tourné vers les
tribunaux donc ce qui s'est encore ce
qu'elle aurait fait en fait elle
n'hésite pas à affirmer que si le débat
revient à nouveau devant les tribunes
devant les tribunaux elle va y
participer quoi qu'elle espère bien que
ce débat est clos maintenant il faut
dire que le gouvernement fédéral a quand
même demandé l'avis de la cour suprême
un avis qui pourraient venir plus tard
échanges et donc la donne pour les
autres femmes qui voudrait prêter
serment en portant le voile mais d'ici
là elle elle aura voté aux élections
fédérales
encore une fois en s'identifiant d'abord
à visage découvert comme elle l'a fait
aujourd'hui très bien mis une chose qui
est certaine le débat n'est pas clos
certains enfants rentrent en parlait il
ya des projets qui arrivent dans les
médias sociaux voilà merci au revoir